[Music]
we live in a world now where there is an
economic model that strongly
incentivizes online platforms like
Facebook Google Twitter to capture as
much of our attention as possible the
way to do that is is to promote content
that is the most engaging and what is
the most engaging moral content there
was a recent study that came out of NYU
recently that characterized the language
in tweets and this study which was led
by William Brady and Jay Ben Babel and
colleagues found that each moral
emotional word in a tweet increase the
likelihood of a retweet by 20% so
content that has moral and emotional
qualities to it of which moral outrage
is the poster child is the most engaging
content and so that means that the
algorithms that select for what is shown
to all of us in our news feeds are
selecting for the content that's going
to be the most engaging because that
draws the most attention because that
creates the most revenue through ad
sales for these companies and so this
creates an information ecosystem where
there's a kind of natural selection
process going on and the most outrageous
content is going to rise to the top so
this suggests that the kinds of stories
that we read in our news feeds on line
might be artificially inflated in terms
of how much outrage they provoke and
I've actually found some data that
speaks to this so there was a study a
few years ago by wil Hoffman Linda's
Kitka and colleagues at the University
of Chicago where they tracked people's
daily experiences with moral and immoral
events in their everyday lives and they
pinged people's smartphones a few times
a day and had them rate whether in the
past hour they had had
the moral or immoral experiences and
they had people rate how emotional they
felt how outraged they felt how happy
and so on this data became publicly
available and so I was able to reanalyze
the data because these researchers had
asked them where did you learn about
these immoral events online in person on
TV radio newspaper etc and so I was able
to analyze this data and show that
immoral events that people learn about
online trigger more outraged than
immoral events that they learn about in
person or through traditional forms of
media like TV newspaper and radio so
this supports the idea that the
algorithms that drive the presentation
of news content online are selecting
that content that provokes perhaps
higher levels of outrage then we even
see on the news and of course what we
see normally in our daily lives it's an
open question what are the long-term
consequences of this constant exposure
to outrage triggering material one
possibility that has been floated in the
news recently is outrage fatigue and I
think many of us can relate to the idea
that if you're constantly feeling
outraged and it's exhausting and there
may be a limit to how much outrage were
able to experience day to day that is
potentially harmful in terms of the long
term social consequences because if we
are feeling outraged about relatively
minor things and that's depleting some
kind of reserve that may mean that we're
not able to feel outraged for things
that really matter on the other hand
there is also research in aggression
showing that if you give people the
opportunity to vent their aggressive
feelings about something that's made
them mad that actually can increase the
likelihood of future aggression so
in the literature on anger and outrage
there are two possibilities one being
this long term depletion outreach
fatigue the other being a kind of
sensitization and we need to do more
research to to figure out which of those
might be operating in the context of
online outrage expression it may be
different for different people social
media is very unlikely to go away
because it taps into the things that we
find most rewarding connection with
others expressing our moral values
sharing those moral values with others
building our reputation and of course
what makes social media so compelling
and so so addictive even is the fact
that these platforms are really tapping
into very ancient neural circuitry that
that we know are involved in reward
processing in habit formation one
intriguing possibility because the way
these apps are designed are so
streamlined you have stimuli icons that
are that are so recognizable and
familiar to all of us who use these apps
and very effortless responses to like to
share to retweet and then we get
feedback and that feedback in the form
of likes and shares is delivered at
unpredictable times and unpredictable
rewards we know from decades of research
in neuroscience are the fastest way to
establish a habit now habit is a
behavior that is expressed without
regard to its long-term consequences
just as someone who's habitually
reaching for the bag of potato chips
when they're not hungry they're eating
those potato chips not to achieve some
goal to satisfy their hunger but just
mindlessly we might be mindlessly
expressing moral emotions like outrage
without actually necessarily
Aaron Singh them strongly or desiring to
express those so broadly the way that we
just do on social media and so I think
it's really worth considering and having
a conversation about whether we want
some of our strongest moral emotions
which are so core to who we are do we
want those under the control of
algorithms whose main purpose is to
generate advertising revenue for big
tech companies
[Music]